[Musique]
c'est bien c'est qu'ils allaient le
faire pendant au départ c'était
rendez-vous de pêcheurs et j'appelle ça
c'était à 1000 ainsi que recevoir sa
cabane entier venus avant moi ce cabanon
ça se raconte pas le cas banon c'est
toute notre vise d'abord le monde de la
chance d aller vers le cabanon c'est un
endroit comme il faisait de la danse et
des besoins des riches habitants
on est souvent entre nous entre hommes
ont bien y jouer la sortie de bouloc
on doit faire tout un tas de choses
qu'on ne sait pas si c'est une chose le
canada comment vous le diront c'est bien
difficile il faut le vivre pour pouvoir
leur pouvoir pour pouvoir le faire pour
pouvoir le voir pour pouvoir le
comprendre
qu'est ce que je pourrais vous dire de
plus que ça si un jour vous avez
l'occasion menées ont bousillé englobera
aux cavs à nantes
si vous savez et bien c'est pas sûr que
vous retourniez ailleurs
c'est à dire alarme allons avoir une
foule était arrivé c'est impossible et
supporte même pas le soleil tant de
violence ou le mans ne m'interdis si
aujourd'hui ils n'en feront pas commis
alors voilà le bouleverse à d'abord il
faut l'étudier avant le mauvais tir
celui oliva parlement rachida celui des
oignons de l'ail ce qui détourne du
persil les pommes de terre coupées à
coin le savent pas ça y est on appellera
ça ferme à serena williams et après
allons vous mettez l'eau passer regarder
même bosser quand tu ne gagnes un temps
on voyait la couleur et d'un restaurant
comme ça vaut la musique et que c'est
pas une année malheureuse ne le servez
là c'est une bouille et façades aux
riches qu'on a on a bien le pêcheur à a
surtout pour le prier alors une voix ya
bien ça pour qu'elle soit supérieure
[Musique]
alors là vous la baisse supérieure
bombée ont mal à séduire un elle avait
pas tomber dans la peur la mannschaft et
les médias
à voir la bouteille parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'affaires et chic et tous de
matelot d'alger abdiqué mais aussi de
tous mes souvenirs fait de bonheur et
d'un fort est une
le plus fidèle à revenir et mon village
au clair de lune
[Musique]